ladies and gentlemen i am with none
other than world record holder
dr kathy sullivan
famous astronaut first american woman to
walk in space
it's been 30 years since your fantastic
sts-31 mission right and lego wanted to
commemorate that brilliant amazing event
and so they came up with this two scale
2
354 piece space shuttle
it is for 18 years and older and i love
that because lego's done a phenomenal
job of really creating content for
generations first let's talk about this
front area you see the windows in the
upper deck here that's where four people
would be sitting for launch and landing
that's where you'd operate from while
you're doing this because you've got
windows back here and windows here in
the entire shuttle there's only about
this much right up here
that holds air it's pressurized it's the
same pressure as we have right here
and it's got two and a half decks it's
got the deck below is where the airlock
is and storage lockers usually where we
would sleep either just drifting around
a bit or maybe tethered onto one of the
walls it's not very big in any dimension
inside this crew module they've even got
the docking ring and the umbilical black
on the telescope and yeah that is very
cool these little yellow guys here we
called them the milk stools why they
called milk stills they look like
milking stools that you might sit on
when you're milking a cow but their job
was just to be sort of bumpers so that
if the telescope vibrated when it was
bolted in the payload bay this is sort
of the delicate part of it it wouldn't
bash against the size of the cargo bay
on our mission when we took coupled
orbit for the first time
we didn't have any cradle like this to
hold hubble because it filled almost the
whole cargo bay itself
and it would have been nestled all the
way down in the bay and and held in by
some latches back here so this could
actually fit inside the telescope and
you'd close these flaps in the cargo bay
yeah yeah so these solar rays would have
been retracted
onto these beams and then those beams
would be folded up along the side sure
it would all fit down on the cargo bay
fantastic i mean this is unbelievable
and i appreciate the fact that you said
lego got this right even the canada arm
is actually looking legit as well right
it's very cool this is super duper tough
to be part of team hubble and be sort of
what we call a navy a plank owner you
helped get it built and get it started
that was a five-year span it was
one-third of my career at nasa was
involved with getting all the equipment
needed to repair hubble in orbit
ready and tested and positively assured
that it would work
so find me some other satellite that's
improved a thousand times while it was
in orbit and live to twice its life
that's the magic of hubble anyone who's
been on team hubble it's like the
signature thing of their space career
sign up to lego vip to watch the full
interview with dr catherine sullivan to
find out more about her mission as well
as her thoughts on the future of space
exploration and encouraging more young
people into the extraordinary world of
stem